[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Successful people
make it look so easy,
but they never said it was.
He was rejected by
Harvard Business School.
Warren Buffett is now the most
successful investor in history.
He was fired from 4 jobs and
forced to live in his car
on $2.50 a day.
John Paul Dejoria, co-founder
of the Patron Spirits
Company and John Paul
Mitchell hair systems.
After bombing the law school
admissions test twice,
she spent 8 years working
for a company that
sold fax machines door to door.
Sara Blakely founded the
shapewear company, Spanx,
and is now a billionaire.
He pitched his television
show to everyone,
but it was rejected
all over Hollywood.
Matthew Weiner's "Mad Men"
finally made to the screen,
seven years after
it was written.
In her teens, she was
tormented and bullied
for being overweight.
Jillian Michaels now runs a
health and wellness empire.
After starting his own
architectural practice,
he was on the verge of
bankruptcy for years.
Frank Gehry is one of the
most important architects
of our age.
After years of failed attempts,
this former swimsuit model
finally launched her own
brand with a line of socks.
Kathy Ireland's name now
graces over 15,000 products.
Yep, she's bigger
than Martha Stewart.
He was kicked out of 9
schools and repeatedly told
that he would end up in prison.
Hans Zimmer is one of the
most successful composers
of our time.
Ever seen "The Lion King?"
How do they do it?
Find out, and
learn their secrets
in "Getting There, A Book of
Mentors," by Gillian Zoe Segal.
[END PLAYBACK]
GILLIAN ZOE SEGAL: So why
did I write this book?
There's a common misperception
that highly successful people
were practically born
that way, that they either
had a meteoric rise to the
top, or at the very least,
enjoyed some smooth,
steady climb.
And the truth couldn't
be further from this.
But even when you
know this, you still
can't help but
look at a luminary
and imagine that he or she
had a somewhat easier time
than you might have
getting to where they are.
And even if you know that
that person encountered
specific obstacles, you imagine
that those obstacles probably
didn't faze them that much.
Now, conversely, when you
are working towards something
and you encounter
an obstacle when
you fail or you
get rejected, it's
easy to blow that
out of proportion.
It's easy to get depressed.
It's easy to get
discouraged, and it's
easy to let those emotions
take you off track.
So what do you do about this?
The best way to ensure that
you persevere and reach
your own potential
is to get inspiration
from the lives and careers of
people who you really admire.
Learn details about
the difficulties
that these people
encountered and see how
they were able to move forward.
Then, make a point of recalling
these lessons and anecdotes
when you need a boost.
So this is what I set out
to provide with my book,
"Getting There."
I sat down with 30 leaders
from a broad variety of fields,
and I got as personal as
they would let me get.
I asked them to let their guards
down and share their stories.
And I asked them to tell
me about their lowest
lows and the lessons they
learned from their journey.
I also asked them to distill
the best advice and wisdom
that they had to offer.
And while I was added,
I also photographed
each of these
people, because who
doesn't like a book with
some pictures in it?
It makes it easier to
relate to the people.
So before I really get
into the meat of the book,
I just want to say
one thing, which
is that no one knows it all.
And what speaks to
me in these essays
might be different than
what speaks to you or you.
We all need help
in different areas.
And one of the nicest things
recently that's happened
is that I sent a copy
of "Getting There"
to each of the 30
subjects in the book.
And so many of
them got back to me
and told me how much
they were enjoying
reading each other's
stories, and that they
were learning from each other.
So after that
feedback, I can feel
confident in saying
that there's something
in the book for anybody.
Warren Buffett.
As you saw in the video, he got
rejected from Harvard Business
School.
But there's more.
He's had a harder
times than that.
Up until the age of 20, he
was petrified of speaking
in public.
This was so bad that
he would literally
arrange his whole life so that
he never had to find himself
in front of a crowd.
And if he did have
to speak in public,
he would literally throw
up before doing so.
So when he was 20, he decided
he had to get over this,
and he signed up for a Dale
Carnegie public speaking
course.
And this changed his life.
If you go to his office, he
has his $100 course certificate
from the Dale Carnegie
School framed on his wall.
And he has nothing
else-- no other diplomas,
because he says that that
course has had the biggest
impact on his subsequent success
than any other degree he has.
Well, to say that Warren
Buffett is a wealth of wisdom
is an understatement.
His essay has so
many amazing lessons.
But I'm just going to talk
about a couple of them
so we can get to other
people in the book.
One of the things
that Warren taught me
is that you can always tell
someone to go to hell tomorrow.
And this is a piece
of advice that he
got from a friend of
his about 50 years ago.
And he says its one of
the most valuable things
he's ever learned.
And I have to say that out of
all the tidbits in my book,
it's probably the one bit of
advice that I pass on the most
frequently.
The point of it is that you
should refrain from spouting
off in a moment of anger.
When you do that, you
often say something
that you might regret,
and you can't take back.
So Warren says, just
forget about it for a day.
If you feel the same way
tomorrow, tell them then.
You haven't missed
the opportunity.
Warren also talked
about passion.
And this is something that
almost everybody in my book
talked about.
So I'm going to bring it up
now and get it over with.
They all say that you
should pursue something
that you're passionate about.
And the reason why is
because nothing is easy.
And if you're not passionate
about what you're doing,
you'll never have the fuel to
jump the inevitable hurdles
that you're going to encounter.
They also say that you
should not do something just
for the money, or you
shouldn't do something
because you think you should.
Because if you go
down that road,
it probably won't end very well.
Hans Zimmer, who is
a famous composer,
he discussed the subject
during our interview.
And he said, whenever I need
legal or medical advice,
I go announce my
problems to my orchestra.
Half are doctors, and half
are lawyers whose parents
forced them into those jobs.
So Warren Buffett takes this
passion thing a step further.
And he says, not only
should you do something
you're passionate
about, but it's also
important to understand your
strengths and weaknesses,
and do something
within what he calls,
your circle of competence.
So he says that knowing
what to leave out
is as important as
knowing what to focus on.
And he quotes his
friend, Tom Watson,
who's the founder of IBM
who said, I'm no genius.
But I'm smart in spots, and
I stay around those spots.
An example of someone
who was fortunate enough
to discover his
circle of competence
is Nitin Nohria, who is
the current dean of Harvard
Business School.
He grew up in India, in a
typical, middle class family.
And his parents
wanted him to become
either a doctor or an engineer.
So he decided to
become an engineer,
and he applied for the most
prestigious school there, which
is IIT.
And we have a
graduate of IIT here.
So anyway, Nitin did not
get in on his first try,
which was a very traumatic
experience for him.
But he did get in
on his second try.
And when he finally
got to school, he says,
he managed to become a
pretty decent student.
But he would look around,
and there were people there
who could do things
in their sleep
that he couldn't do, no
matter how hard he tried.
And so after IIT, he went
to MIT to study finance.
And the same thing happened.
So finally, after a lot
of internal struggle,
he allowed himself to
change paths and pursue
something less technical.
He became a professor,
and the rest is history.
He rose right to the
top of his field,
and he's the dean of Harvard.
And he wants to
make a point though.
He wants to make
sure that the lesson
to take away from
his story is not
to change paths the moment you
discover something's difficult,
because if you give
up at first blush,
you'll never
succeed at anything,
because nothing
worth doing is easy.
As much as any of you
love it here at Google,
and as long as you've
been here, and as
well as you think you're doing
here, you might get fired.
Why am I bringing this up with
a picture of Michael Bloomberg
right there?
Because that happened to him.
Michael Bloomberg is now one of
the richest men in the world,
and he is the founder
of Bloomberg LP.
And he also is the
mayor of New York City
for three consecutive terms.
But before all of that, he
worked at Salomon Brothers.
And he loved it.
He was there for 15 years.
He thought he was doing great.
But the company got sold.
They restructured,
and he got the boot.
No one came running to
offer him another job,
so he decided that he would
just start his own company.
And that's how
Bloomberg was born.
And one thing that really struck
me about him in our interview
is that we all know
that to get anywhere,
you have to work hard.
But he really gave working
hard a new meaning.
Even after he got
fired from Salomon,
he still had about two
months left before he
was going to leave the company.
And he made sure to still
work six days a week
from as early in the morning
until as late as he could.
He was even looking for
office space during that time.
And he told the broker
that he could only
look on weekends, because he
didn't want anyone to ever say
that he didn't work 110%.
He said he had an ego
problem with that.
So something that a lot of
people in my book demonstrate
is the careers have chapters.
And even if it's not
because you got fired,
what you're doing
right now might not
be what you're going to be
doing a few years from now.
You do not need to have
everything mapped out.
But the subjects in my book
say that the important thing
is to always keep your eyes
open for new possibilities.
Leslie Moonves is the
president and CEO of CBS.
He began his career as an actor.
But at a certain point, he
got sick of being a bartender
to make ends meet.
And then he realized
that he'd actually
prefer being on the
other side of the camera.
And he says that if
your path is too rigid,
you're likely to miss
out on opportunities.
You have to be fluid
and open to change.
Jillian Michaels, who now runs
a health and wellness empire,
she only devoted
herself to her field
after being fired
as a talent agent.
And Kathy Ireland started
out her career as a model,
and she became a very successful
"Sports Illustrated" swimsuit
model.
And she now runs a $2
billion a year business,
and it's called kathy
ireland Worldwide.
And her name graces
over 15,000 products.
A lot of people look
at her and think,
if I was born looking like
that, or if I had been a "Sports
Illustrated" swimsuit model, I
could slap my name on products
and make a lot of money too.
But that is not the case.
So before Kathy finally hit it,
she tried and failed for years.
She tried a skin care
line, a beer company,
several different art projects.
They all flopped.
And finally, she was
able to launch her brand
with of all things, a pair of
socks-- Kathy Ireland socks.
But just because
it launched doesn't
mean it was easy either.
She talks in her essay
about traveling around
with her backpack and sleeping
in airports to save money.
And she also talks about a
time when her company almost
went bankrupt.
Kathy says that a lot of
times, people come up to her,
and they tell her
about a business idea
that they started,
but then they stopped,
because either someone
they knew didn't
think it was such a smart idea,
or they faced some rejection.
And she says to them, you
stopped because of that?
"If you never fail it means
you're not trying hard enough."
And that is a another
big theme in the book.
My subjects all say that
you should not be paralyzed
by the fear of failure.
Everyone fails,
and you just have
to think of it as
part of the process.
So John Paul Dejoria-- he is the
founder of John Paul Mitchell
systems, which is a super
successful line of hair care
products.
And he is also the founder
of the Patron Spirits Company
that makes the
delicious tequila.
He grew up without much money.
And when I say
without much money,
his father left the
family when he was two,
and so it was just him, and
his brother, and his mother.
And he remembers a time when
between the three of them,
they had $0.27.
So he never went to college.
He went to the Navy
instead, because he
had no money to go to college.
And then he had a series
of different jobs.
And he also got fired from
a series of different jobs.
And he ended up living in
his car on $2.50 a day.
And in the essay,
he describes how
he worked that,
where he showered,
what he had for breakfast,
what he had for dinner.
But one of the most
surprising things
I found in putting
this book together
was how many of these
really successful people
credited early jobs in
sales for giving them
the skills they needed for
their ultimate success.
And John Paul Dejoria
is an example of that.
One of his early jobs
was selling encyclopedias
door to door.
And he did this for three years.
And he says it was one of the
most formative experiences
of his life, and says that
if that job existed today,
he would make every one
of his children do it.
What he had to do was go
around, knock on doors,
convince people to the first
to let him make a presentation,
and then he would
try to convince
them to buy a set of
encyclopedias for their family.
And a lot of doors got
slammed in his face.
So this taught him to
overcome rejection,
and it also taught him to really
hone his powers of persuasion.
He explains that
after you've had
15 doors slammed
in your face, you
need to be as enthusiastic
at the 16th door
as you were at the first door
if you want to make a sale.
And when he ultimately launched
his first successful business,
which was the John
Paul Mitchell systems,
he relied on these skills
to make it a success.
He went from beauty
salon to beauty salon,
convincing them to
try buy his product.
And he says that at least 4
out of 5 turned them down.
But he knew better than to
let that discourage him.
Another person who obviously
did not let failure or rejection
paralyze him is Matthew Weiner.
And he is the creator of
the hit TV show, "Mad Men."
And as you saw on
the video, that
was rejected all over Hollywood,
and it took seven years
from the time he wrote it
until when it was onscreen.
But that was not his only
experience with rejection.
Well, Matt went to
USC Film School.
And when he graduated,
he could not get a job.
And he couldn't
even get a meeting
with an agent who would
try to find him a job.
So he spent three years
writing spec scripts from home.
I'm going to read the way
he describes those years.
He said, my friends had
day jobs, but I didn't.
My wife, Linda, worked hard as
an architect and supported us.
I attempted to shop my material
around, but nothing sold.
I got very bitter seeing
people I didn't think
deserved it succeed.
It was a dark time.
Show business looked
so impenetrable
that I eventually
stopped writing.
I begin watching TV all
day and lying about it.
My mother would call me
to drive my brother-in-law
to the airport.
That's the kind of
crap I was doing
instead of being a writer.
I felt like the most useless,
worthless person in the world.
Well, Matt also gave some
advice that I'm going to share.
I'll share just
two pieces of it.
The first is something that
might seem really basic.
But Matt says that it took
him forever to get this.
And it's just when you have
a meeting with somebody,
look that person up,
and now everything
you can about him or her.
It's pretty effortless,
and it can pay dividends.
The other piece of
advice I'm going to share
is he says when someone
rejects your work,
you have to listen to the
fact that they don't like it.
But don't listen
to the reason why.
And he says that a
lot of times, people
feel like they have
to say something.
But they don't want
to hurt your feelings,
so they give some kind
of a capricious reason.
And if you alter your
work for every rejection,
you're just going to go running
in all different directions
trying to please an
imaginary audience.
And that can be damaging
and destructive.
So with "Mad Men,"
Matt stuck to his guns.
And what ended up
on the screen is
what he had originally
planned, and what
had been rejected for years.
David Boies is one of the
world's most highly acclaimed
attornies.
A case he was in that was
relevant to you here at Google
is that he represented the
US Department of Justice
in its successful antitrust
suit against Microsoft.
He has a surprising history.
First, David suffers
from dyslexia
and couldn't read until
he was in third grade.
And then when he
graduated high school,
he had no intention
of going to college.
He just wanted to live
a carefree lifestyle.
He wanted to surf.
So he got jobs in
construction to make money.
And basically, he made the
most money from playing cards.
And this changed when
his wife got pregnant.
And she nudged him to get a
little bit more responsible.
And that's when he
went to law school,
and the rest is
history with him too.
But basically, his field
has a lot of ups and down.
He has won a lot of
great cases, and he
has lost a lot of great cases.
So I talked to him about this.
And he gave me some
advice that I really
like, because it's applicable
to all aspects of life
and all careers.
And he said, no
matter what you do,
there will be times
when things go well,
and times when things go badly.
The only thing for
sure in either scenario
is that things will change.
When something good
happens, I try to enjoy it.
When something
bad happens, I try
to understand why it happened.
But in either case, the next
day, I'm onto something else.
So keep up that forward motion.
None of the subjects in my
book allow them themselves
to wallow for too
long in anything.
They all try to learn
something from their mistakes
and failure.
And then they just move on.
So unlike David Boies,
this is Sara Blakely.
And her whole life was geared
towards being a lawyer.
Her father was a trial attorney.
She used to take days off of
school to go watch him in court
and take notes.
She joined the debate team
so that her law school
application would look
good, and she'd be prepared.
And then when the time finally
came for her to take the LSAT,
she bombed it.
So she took a course,
studied as hard as she could.
Took it again, and she
did one point worse.
So after this, Sarah got a
job loading rides at Disney.
And then she spent eight years
working for a company that
sold fax machines door to door.
She's another one who
talks about the benefits
that this gave her.
But one thing that she
talked about in her essay
that I'm going to share
with you is she talk
about the important--
well, I need to get back
to what she actually did.
One day, while she was
working for the company that
sold fax machines
door to door, she
saw that her butt didn't look
so good in her white pants.
So she wished that
she had something
like control-top pantyhose that
she could wear underneath them,
but without the whole
leg part; without feet.
So she invented that product.
It's now called Spanx.
I can't imagine that any
woman in this audience
doesn't know what
Spanx is, and it's
been joked about and publicized.
She was actually on
the cover of "Forbes,"
because she's a billionaire
from this product.
So she talks about
the importance
of keeping a young idea secret.
And she explains
that because ideas
are the most vulnerable at
the moment you have them,
hearing discouraging remarks
early on will likely take you
off course.
You'll either end up
deflated or spend your time
defending your idea
instead of going for it.
She kept her idea
secret for a year.
She told her
friends and families
that she was working
on something,
but she wouldn't tell them what.
And when she finally told them
that the idea was footless
pantyhose, they laughed at her.
And when they were
done laughing,
she heard comments like, well,
honey, if it is a good idea,
then why haven't the
big guys done it?
But by that point, she was
too invested to give up.
And she says the
she's pretty positive
that if she had told her friends
and family about Spanx early
on, she would still be selling
fax machines door to door.
Someone else who talks
about the importance
of keeping a young idea secret,
but for different reasons,
is Jeff Kinney.
He is the author of the
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid"
series, which is a wildly
successful series of books.
There's over 115 million
of them in print right now.
And there's also been
a couple movies made.
And his history, that ever
since he was in college,
he aspired to be a
newspaper cartoonist.
But the problem was he could
not get his cartoon syndicated
in a newspaper.
And he tried really hard.
He says, I would spend between
six and nine months putting
together a submission
packet, and then
send it out to all
the syndicates,
only to get really tough,
terse rejection letters back.
This went on for a few years.
And it was very soul sucking.
So what he did was he spent
eight years writing his book,
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid."
But he protected
himself during that time
by telling very few
people about it.
And he explains that when you
broadcast your intentions,
you're likely to
either get embarrassed
if you're unable to
deliver, or become
trapped by the social
pressure to follow through.
And if you keep an
idea to yourself,
you can maintain
more flexibility.
And that's something
that's really necessary.
Being able to switch
directions when you need to
is often really necessary
to produce something great.
This is Anderson Cooper.
And something that is not
included in his essay,
but it seems like it's
something a lot of people know,
is that his mother
is Gloria Vanderbilt.
And he comes from the
Vanderbilt family,
which is a very wealthy family.
So a lot of times, people
have said things to me
like oh, I'm sure he didn't
have much trouble getting
to where he is, and he probably
had a lot of connections.
And this is so not the case.
First of all, his
essay starts like this.
My father died during
heart bypass surgery
when I was 10 years old.
When I was 21, my 23-year-old
brother committed suicide.
He jumped off the terrace of
our family's penthouse apartment
as my mother pleaded
for him to stay put.
I think that any time you
experience traumatic loss early
on, it changes who you are
and drastically affects
your view of the world.
At least that was
the case with me.
So he talks about the
tough emotional time
he had from those experiences.
But he eventually
was able to move on,
and he decided that he
wanted to be a foreign news
correspondent.
The problem was,
despite any connections
you might think he had, he
couldn't get an entry level job
at any of the major networks.
And he tried.
But finally, a friend
from high school
told him about
Channel One, which
is an agency that produces
youth oriented news
problems for high schools.
And he was able to get a
job as a fact checker there.
And he realized pretty soon
that when you work at a company,
people there tend to pigeonhole
you in whatever role you're in.
And sometimes, you have to
do something really drastic
to change people's
perception of you.
So what he did was he quit
his job as a fact checker,
and he went overseas to
shoot stories by himself.
And he made the stories as
interesting and dangerous
as possible, then offered
to sell them to Channel One
for such a low price that it
was hard for them to refuse.
And that is how he launched
his career, which leads me
to another big theme, which is
create your own opportunities.
A lot of people in the book
say that you should not
wait for someone to
recognize a talent in you
and offer you something.
If you want something
to happen, you
have to make it happen yourself.
This is Jim Koch.
And he got a JD MBA
at Harvard, and then
had a really high paying job
at the Boston Consulting Group.
And it was the kind of job
that a lot of his peers
would be very jealous of.
But he was totally unhappy.
And his dream was to start
his own microbrewery,
but he was really worried
about risking it all
to embark on a startup.
And this changed when he
realized the simple thing,
which is that if his
entrepreneurial venture didn't
pan out, he would always be
able to rejoin the workforce
and get another job that
he wasn't crazy about.
But the real, while
starting his own business
seemed like a risky thing
to do, the real risk
was wasting years
of his life stuck
in something that
appeared attractive
but that he didn't enjoy.
And Jim is the founder of
the Boston Beer Company
that produces Sam Adams
beer, which I'm sure,
everybody has had.
So the biggest risk is
often not taking a risk.
And this is another
big theme in the book.
So many of the subjects
stressed that in order
to accomplish anything, you
have to put yourself out
there and take some risk.
And that leads me to my next
subject, J. Craig Venter.
He is a scientist, and
he was the first person
to sequence the human genome.
And I didn't know exactly what
this meant before I researched
him to go interview
him, so I'm just
going to spell it out for you.
And sequencing the
human genome basically
means reading a human's DNA.
And the medical possibilities
that this information
can lead to are endless.
For example, if you know
what genes a person has,
you know how likely they are
to develop various diseases.
So you might think that a
genius scientist like this
would have done well in
school, but not this one.
He spent most of
his career sitting
in the back of the classroom
throwing spit balls
at the professors, the
teachers, with his friend,
who is an actual member
of Hell's Angels.
He said in seventh
grade, his best friend
had been flunked so many
times that he was old enough
to be a Hell's Angel.
And then Craig almost
flunked out of school.
He actually slid by on a D-.
They had him write
one extra paper.
And he says it
was to get him out
of there, because he
was sure they don't
want to see his face anymore.
So after school,
similar to David Boies,
he did not want
to go to college.
He wanted to surf, and
that's what he did.
He moved to Southern California
and surfed during the day,
and he got jobs to make money
like putting price tags on toys
at Sears and being a baggage
handler at the airport.
But the draft eventually got
in the way of this lifestyle.
And next thing you know,
he was sent off to Vietnam.
And he joined the
Medical Corpsman school.
And when he got there,
he was completely
traumatized by what he saw.
He saw hundreds to thousands
of people his own age
dying every day, and he
didn't believe in what
America was doing there.
And he found this situation
to be overwhelming,
and he, after a few months,
decided to commit suicide.
So I'll read you
his description.
He said, I went to the
beach, got in the water,
and started swimming out to sea.
My plan was to keep going
until I was exhausted,
then sink into the dark
waters in oblivion.
More than a mile out,
I saw a venomous sea
snake surface to breathe.
I began to have doubts
about what I was doing,
but I continued on until
I encountered a shark.
I was instantaneously
consumed with fear.
All thoughts of dying departed,
and I realized that I very much
wanted to live.
I wanted to live more than
I ever had in my previous 21
years of my life.
I turned around, and
driven by sheer adrenalin,
swam for the shore
in a state of panic.
Once I made it to safety,
I never looked back.
Something inside me had changed.
I wanted my life
to mean something.
I wanted to make a
difference in the world.
I wanted to do
something to make up
for everything I saw in
Vietnam and honor those who
were already beyond my help.
So at first, Craig
thought that he
would become a doctor in
a third world country.
But then, he realized
eventually that he
could make the biggest
impact on the world
if he was a scientist.
And basically, he ended up
rising to the top of his field
by going out on
professional limbs
that very few people would.
He had a highly coveted
job with the government,
trying to sequence
the human genome.
But he thought that
he had a better
idea for a method
that would work
more efficiently and quicker.
And they weren't
up for trying it,
so he left his government job,
and he started his own company.
And it was based on a theory
that most of his peers
thought would not work.
And when he started
his own company,
his peers viciously
attacked him,
because his new
method was a threat
to their way of doing things.
But Craig explains that his
time serving in Vietnam really
helped him put things
in perspective.
He says that out there, he had
to worry about risking his life
multiple times a day.
But being back in the
comfort of America,
with his life
relatively protected,
career risks seemed
pretty trivial.
And in the end, he was right.
His method works.
And it's now the
method that is used
by all of his early critics.
So another theme in the
book that this demonstrates
is that you have to question
everything, but then
expect resistance to new
ideas and approaches.
My subjects say that
challenging conventional wisdom
and questioning
authority is essential
for creative
progress, and that you
have to remember that just
because something has been
done one way for
years, doesn't mean
that another way won't work.
And it doesn't mean that
that's the best way.
But watch out, because
people don't like change.
Sometimes it's a
threat to people's way
of doing something, so you're
going to get resistance.
This is Frank
Gehry, an architect.
And he says that he has
always looked at things
and thought, how do we
have to do it that way?
Can't it be done another way?
And he says that
that trait has been
really critical to his work.
But the things he
designed don't really
conform to any particular
architectural philosophy.
And he is now called one of
the most important architects
of our age.
I'm just going to show
you this example of one
of his buildings.
This is the Walt Disney
Concert Hall in Los Angeles.
But when Frank was in
architecture school,
in his second year, a professor
called him into his office,
and sat him down
and said, Frank,
you are never going to
make it in this field.
You should get out now.
You're wasting a lot of time.
And then even when he
started his own practice,
many of his colleagues
were dismissive of him
and made fun of his work.
But like Craig Venter, they've
turned into supporters.
This is Muhammad Yunus.
He grew up in Bangladesh,
and he became a professor.
And back then, the country
was in a terrible state.
There were destitute people
roaming the streets starving,
and Muhammad Yunus wanted
to do something to help.
So he did something unheard of.
He knew that if he
gave these poor people
just a little bit of
money, it could drastically
change their life.
So he wanted to
start a bank that
lent to the poorest of the poor
in small amounts, and to women.
And this was unheard of.
He was told that his
idea was foolish,
that it would never work.
He was attacked.
But he founded the
Grameen Bank anyway,
and he won a Nobel
Prize for his work.
And he explains, if you observe
something that bothers you,
make your own action
plan to fix it.
There are many things that have
been designed in the wrong way.
Don't think that other
people know more than you.
Your theory may be right, and
you can become the new expert.
This is Ian Schrager.
He came into the limelight
when he and his partner, Steve
Rubell, opened the legendary
nightclub, Studio 54,
in New York.
It became wildly successful, and
they became wildly intoxicated
with their success.
And they started thinking that
the rules didn't apply to them.
They didn't pay income
taxes, and they got caught.
And they got sent to
prison for 13 months.
He lost everything.
And when he got out of prison,
he was almost $2 million
in debt.
But eventually, and he
describes how in his essay,
he was able to get
back on his feet
and reinvent himself as a
hotelier and a real estate
investor.
And in a really big
way, he's responsible
for the whole boutique
hotel revolution.
But this whole ordeal
set him back 10 years.
So that's how long
it took for him
to get back from to where he
was before he went to prison.
He calls himself proof that
the prison system works,
and he also says there's
very little in life
that you can't recover
from with hard work.
But out of all of
my subjects, I think
he sums up a major theme
in the book the best.
And he says in the
end, there's so little
that separates people.
Those who want success
the most and are
relentless about pursuing
it are the ones who get it.
And I'm going to end with
one last quote from me.
What could this mean?
A lot of people have asked me
what the most common thread
between my subjects is.
And I thought, it's such
a diverse group of people.
But they're all moles from
that game, Whac-A-Mole.
If you don't know what
I'm talking about,
this is the game
I'm talking about.
You see it in carnivals
where the little mole
pops its head up, and you whack
it, and whack it, and whack it.
Well, it seems like life whacks
us all over the head from time
to time.
It could be in big
ways, and in small ways,
and in ways that have
to do with our career,
or our personal life.
And the people in my book
are all where they are today
because even after getting
whacked multiple times,
they also found a way to
pop their heads back up out
of the hole.
They might have gone
down in the hole
for a little bit,
licked their wounds,
felt sorry for themselves.
They all learned
from their mistakes.
But in the end,
they popped back up.
And I think that's what you
have to do in this world,
because as David Boies
says, there inevitably
are going to be ups and downs.
So the next time any of
you get a little whack,
think of the people
in getting there,
remember Whac-A-Mole,
and then figure out
a way to get yourself out of
whatever hole you might be in.
Done.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So we're
open for questions now.
Just raise your hand,
and I'll stop by.
AUDIENCE: I was
just curious, how
did you get all
these people to agree
to be a part of your book?
GILLIAN ZOE SEGAL:
Well, that was hard.
It took me over
five years to do.
And basically, I would try
every angle that I could.
I had to be very
politely persistent,
and not take no for an answer.
One thing that's
interesting is a friend
of mine, who has a
saying for everything,
you know those kind of
people, he said, don't ever
take a no from someone
who can't give you a yes.
And what that means is if
you call someone's publicist
and they say, no,
try another door.
If the front door's locked,
go in the back door.
If the back door's locked,
try to climb in a window.
So almost everybody
in my book, I
would say everyone in my
book ignored me for a while.
Then most of them
rejected me for a while.
And then when I
climbed in the window,
they sometimes said yes.
But there's a long list
of people who didn't.
AUDIENCE: So what
was your inspiration
for putting this together?
Why did you want to do this?
GILLIAN ZOE SEGAL: Partly,
I think when I started it,
I thought, people need
to hear these stories.
And like I said in the
beginning of the talk,
it's such a great way
to persevere and to get
inspiration from these.
And then also, I realized
that it was a need that I had.
I wanted role
models and mentors.
And so you pursue something
that you're passionate about.
So it's something I
wanted for myself,
and I also thought that
other people would want it.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
At the risk of seeming
provocative, just humor me.
GILLIAN ZOE SEGAL: OK.
AUDIENCE: So there's
several names here,
and they're remarkable people.
But I'm just wondering,
for every one of these,
there might have been 1,000
other guys who are sticking
stickers on toys, whose lives
did not take them to Vietnam,
for example, and who've
just led lives which
are not recorded in history
as glamorously as some
of these names.
So what role do you think luck,
chance, and circumstance play,
and the narrative fallacy
playing in all of this?
GILLIAN ZOE SEGAL: I think that
luck plays a chance in things.
But I think Mayor Bloomberg,
Michael Bloomberg,
in his speech said, the harder
you work, the luckier you get.
So you're not going
to get lucky sitting
on your couch watching TV.
But if you're out there,
if you're going for it,
you have no way better
chance of getting lucky.
So I don't think
luck is pure luck.
AUDIENCE: I just
have a quick question
as to your choice
for the medium.
I know there's a lot of
talk about like blogs,
or the internet being a
medium for these sorts
of personal narratives, and I
was wondering why and how you
choose to present
this in a book format
as opposed to a blog
or an internet--
GILLIAN ZOE SEGAL: Well,
I think I could do both.
So I like a book,
because to me, when
I read something on a blog
it evaporates into midair.
But when you have a
book, it's something
that you have that's physical,
that you can pass on.
You could give it to
someone in a way that you
can't with a blog.
So I think this makes
like a great gift,
and there's something about
having something physical.
Like I love to
give it to people I
care about in a way that
things that are in the cloud,
you can't do it like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much Gillian.
This was fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]